we're on oh yeah are we on oh yes
good morning Millennials sorry about
that just a little technical difficulty
as we say in the biz world we're not we
just didn't know we were yeah we saw a
finger it said go stop we weren't sure
but what we're about good morning happy
Monday
happy Monday welcome back to the morning
toast it's been a long fruitful weekend
it's been a long active weekend you know
I'm feeling sore in my quads what did
you do
I played tennis twice oh so did we and
obviously like I went I was like I
should use my like I'm gonna take a
lesson in the city no that's actually
how I feel and I think I'm actually
gonna do it it's every time Tiffany once
a summer like I'll go play tennis and be
like been like we should really do this
much right and like we should cuz you
know what it's like a great exercise
like I wasn't dying when I was playing
like now I'm super sore um I got tan and
I just like was that cool girl with her
tennis racquet you know yeah that's
great but I wasn't like the crazy tennis
girl like we spoke about you know yeah
those girls
we played how was how was I campers were
pretty good yes she was good
counts was great who won she did exact
and I beat them beat the Martian Rama
would I be sack out of Seoul okay so
that is the cap of how much you guys
could talk about your weekend because I
can't handle it okay no I'll just like
get it briefly in one sentence please
don't buy into the Hamptons we had a
wonderful weekend it was a great time we
miss our sister Claudia and her sister
Olivia but we still had a really great
time we saw a bright young yesterday at
the surf Lodge she was incredible oh my
god I'm dead first teens holy [ __ ]
bethenny frankel was there we didn't see
her we didn't care to see her because
bright young was everything great that's
so why'd you guys recapture weekend to
be honest like I really had great guys
like nine minutes talking about here to
be honest like I had a great weekend I
just like kept looking down at my phone
and being like [ __ ] you know yeah yeah
he also happened to be posting like
really premium no I don't it was like it
my soul walking away my Instagram
definitely like sucking in and tasting
chat like with your pictures to like
stop okay but it wasn't about you it's
just like hey like this is your - we're
alive and having fun don't you send
family pictures like that to your family
truck I wasn't interested by that I'm
having fun
yes well autumn is back in session my
jeans are on and I feel like they're
gonna stay here for a long time because
I'm feeling the autumnal vibes I'm ready
for like a caramel macchiato chai latte
pumpkin spice latte whatever and and
like a poncho you know I'm sure sure and
then you'll be wearing shorts tomorrow
no I'm not I'm in jeans for the entire
week unless like a heatwave arises you
know and I've got to take matters into
my own hands
understood understood um someone else
but you guys want to talk about and
we're like sitting on our hands here not
talking about our weekend yeah we won't
talk about it please
lucky for you there's so much news today
guys I I couldn't really get it to just
five stories so like I had to ad-lib do
you think that there's any business
there's absolutely no amazing well
because there's too much celeb news and
you know what Monday through Friday as
the biz news and then Saturday Sunday
that people with who make the business
news are busy you know in Hamptons
exactly also I guess Geoffrey up seems
like the closest thing to our business
oh that's true what did he even do in
his time on earth he's just a where he's
finance here yeah honestly to be
regarded as a billionaire financier is
well it it really is like the great it's
honor now he's like the pedophile
billionaire financier so they added like
an extra adjective that like I wouldn't
like but I would love to be regarded as
just a financier I totally agree or a
businessman bow like to be someone's
business man bow and honor truly it is
an honor okay
he's in all that it isn't honor wheels
hemorrhage joining us today oh yeah so
excited meet you our very first Real
Housewives of Orange County I can't
leave we've never had an OC og on the
show which Amber's here a great start to
maybe you know welcoming the OC family
to the toast family 100% so make sure to
leave your questions for her on our
Instagram page we will get them to her
and we're just gonna have a great time
with her but before we do that we must
remember the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast we must
do that for sure and I don't want to you
know
sidetrack or you know go into a tangent
but I would be like so upset like I
would be more upset than I am about your
weekend I would be even more upset if I
didn't tell you guys about today's
episode is sponsored by the spotlight
its 2019 and it's time we talk honestly
about all your latest beauty skincare
and medical aesthetic treatments out
there if you're curious about
injectables fillers facials and
everything in between we've got a great
resource for you the spotlight dot-com
and that's spotlight SPO TL yte medical
esthetics you know cosmetic injectables
fillers fat freezing are not exclusive
hush-hush things anymore they're more
accessible than ever and if you're
interested in making them part of your
routine you need to go to the spotlight
com skincare beauty and aesthetics
explained the spotlight com really
breaks it down for you information and
beauty skincare and medical esthetics
for product for many products and
procedures you're curious about they'll
write about it it's all about getting
educated before you try something new
with spotlight you're not gonna get your
information from someone who's trying to
sell you anything it's more like your
favorite magazine interesting
informative and full of expert
recommendations you love their D
stigmatizing medical esthetics spotlight
it's a judgment-free zone there's no
glossing over details or peach preachy
messaging just information you can use
to make your own decisions
easily chat with aesthetic specialists
and if you decide to move forward with
any aesthetic treatment spot Lee makes
it easy to find a qualified provider
they have a database of over 30,000
local health care professionals if
you're obsessed with beauty skincare and
curious to learn more about medical
esthetics go to the spotlight com /
toast to find out more that's spotlight
with why the SPO TL y te dot-com / toast
one more time that's the spotlight
dot-com / toast
again that's spotlight with y very
helpful and informative database of
information check it out ok so much big
news so in like sort of order of
importance but not really because it
just couldn't decide let me see what do
you think is the most important Jeffrey
Epstein from this weekend know like
valium more important great more run for
the purposes in this person like when
you're a pedophile like you no longer
have you no seniority no over people who
are not pedophiles right so Miley and
Liam are done so then the story didn't
end there
because it was like the craziest most
shook worthy news because Miley and Liam
as far as we know we're solid as a rock
they're in such a good place they
finally got married after all these
years so the news of them being broken
up like was was partially unbelievable
and I just choose so sad and then as if
like the Miley and Liam Stan's couldn't
catch even more of a break all of a
sudden these yacht pictures of Caitlin
Carter and Miley Cyrus making out on a
yacht in Italy Italy shook us even more
so the plot really thickened and I have
to sort we need to figure out like what
is really going on because the news of
Miley and Liam came hours before these
pictures leaked which made me think that
these pictures were gonna leak so they
put it like they knew what they were
getting blackmailed or they had a tip
that that I just spit all over my mouth
jack but like Miley and Liam have been
very like honest and forward about how
they have sort of an unconventional
relationship right and you know I
wouldn't they don't call it an open
relationship but it's not she has said
that she's like a queer person in a
hetero relationship and like what does
that and they're like figuring out the
water she said many an interview where
she kind of talks about how they have
this like unspoken
you know open door in their relationship
so I feel like if these photos had come
out like I wouldn't have thought that
Miley was cheating on Liam I would just
think she was like with her friend and
they're making out yeah so now I'm just
heartbroken and devastate oh but well
I'm more confused like Miley has always
been super open with her sexuality so
like even if we didn't know that they
broke up and these pictures came out it
wouldn't have been confusing but like
I'm really more concerned with the
Caitlin Carter of it all yeah you know
look we know Miley is this really fluid
open person about her sexuality and
that's so great but Caitlin Carter just
coming out of left field you know yeah I
I guess I don't know but then I also
like weirdly ship it all so Miley has
like the best taste in human beings yes
I've heard like every single person that
she's ever with is the most beautiful
person on the show Caitlin I think it's
the most beautiful girl the snitch has
left the building
just slamming the door was it something
we said she's too upset about Miley and
Liam no she by the way about when I
first when you first saw the headline
who did you think of immediately I
thought of snitch
oh I thought of myself being sad no
Margo is like truly the Miley Liam
shipper ever since that movie about them
came out what was it called last time
[Music]
at pier 17 and that's just a coincidence
because we voted on it months back I
remember
so we've learned we're gonna take on new
meaning are you okay slamming the doors
okay okay um sorry what Mylene Liam but
it also really cuts me deep because the
way that they've been portraying these
their relationship like since aids I've
gotten married it was like they figured
it out you know it really makes me like
not believe in love anymore I know they
were each other's person and they were
navigating like social norms and like
what it means to be in a relationship in
2019 like together and I thought they
were doing a great job so like where did
we go wrong
no I know it isn't narrative that I
don't know if like we made up was that
kind of like she every time she wasn't
with Liam like she kind of was like
being a little crazy you know and like
experimenting but going a little wild
like she was not with Liam at the VMAs
and kind of every time she finds back
her she finds her way back to her Center
she also finds her way back to Liam like
he is the equilibrium of her life so now
it's like if she gonna go on another
like you know Miley Cyrus and her dad's
pets moment I don't know she might cuz
like her work her body of work is like
going there like when if you've seen her
recent performances she's like no longer
The Backyardigans like just you know
really being like I just lived yet I
live yes Joan Jett she loves Joan I live
for the Miley we get of Miley and Liam
do you know Damien and I I don't know if
I'm ready cuz I don't really know the
Miley I get like without I know you do
not know the mature but now she's like
much more evolved yeah like you're like
in her own and she's gets who she is
like I I'm curious to see who the Miley
who they mature Miley without Liam is
because I don't know I don't know either
and I'm just I'm really sad because I
thought that they hadn't I thought they
had all the answers you know ya know
they really seemed like they were these
two kids in Hollywood who like had it
figured out yeah but there are so many
different factors that play but they
were like had found balance but now that
ain't so baby so well now like also like
Liam Hemsworth arguably the most
eligible bachelor on the planet like is
available and ready like who gets who
gets that yeah I want him to like find a
great gal and live happily ever after
because like also he I can't imagine
that
he was the one who ended things because
that's the one talking in Daily Mail
Australia is saying it's too hard I
don't want to talk about it mate yeah
and so now he's not only you know been
broken up with the dumpee but he's
watching his wife ex-wife make out with
like the hottest girl in the world in
Italy yeah and my least leg with her
family so this is like a family
sanctioned relations right I saw that
too like everyone knows about it it just
can't get any worse for him I know and
when I think and I don't know this to be
true but I've always gotten the vibe
from their relationship that Liam was
really like the the more stable like the
one who really wanted to settle down and
get married and I just feel like
whatever he looks for next like he's
looking long-term like I think he sees
what his brother has like has such a
nice family like and he wants that and
like he tried to make make that out of
my league but Miley's never been that
type of girl and I think she tried she
wanted to be that girl for him no but
she wasn't even trying like I just
thought he loved her at the way she was
no matter what so it makes me feel like
what could she have done and people are
like I think there was cheating but like
can you be cheating if you're in an open
relationship right so like what could
have gone wrong we're like I thought
they were just like this unit just like
shucking and jiving and dodging through
all the different like curses of
Hollywood no I know and it's just like
what we are we took it for granted we
took it for granted because we like we
never really even spoke about our honor
and how much they really like withstood
the test of time and I think now that I
think about it like I can't believe as
of a week ago like they were still
together after all they went through you
know and we should have spoken about
that more when we had a lady deserve it
and you don't know what you got till
it's gone I also like just didn't want
to curse it and like I feel like the
best chance anyone has is for the
pressure to be taken off and like you
know everyone to just do their thing so
we were letting them do their thing and
they ran it into the ground but okay Bri
that's what you get like when you let
hooligans yeah but now I'm like worried
about all my other favorite people right
who are some of your favorite couples
right now Joe and Sophie oh my god I'm
so worried about them because like
nothing bad can happen to them ever I
want them to have the best life with so
much money and fame and happiness but I
just feel like if they can get through
the x-men premiere in the Game of
Thrones finale at the state on the same
day like they can get through anything
and the Jonas Brothers album release
yeah or like the Jonas Brothers
reconciliation like that was a super
emotional time did you watch a document
so so beautiful that was
we toughened like I'm sure like they
have to dig deep and talk about moments
and feelings that like they haven't
spoken about a long time and like so if
he was there for Joe like I know she was
know and now I'm even here worried about
making Priyanka yeah but like you know
Shelby was like there for gel like with
a jewel pod you know oh for sure but I
just think I can't have anything happen
to like the couple's Jonas but I also
can't have anything happen to the Jonas
Brothers nor the J sisters what do you
guys think they're kicked off their tour
over the weekend in Miami in Orlando and
they've been like posting pictures and
like some clips like it looks [ __ ]
late we're going of course I'm gonna
call on my favorite for that you know
yeah where they playing Madison Square
Garden oh cool that's really cool this
Mitch how are you feeling about Miley
and Liam that's what we said like the
first person I thought of when I heard
it was you take us max Mitch yeah it
looks like she might be heading back
down he's looking for the ELSA to his
Chris yeah we all do you gotta take it
all and it's not like he doesn't know
that this part of her you know exists
you know you can selectively love
someone right and I don't think he was
like I think he was down for it all I
had like I really think it was on her
terms that this ended right maybe he
said no to something no okay like this
is like friends with Ross and Emily
Marga remember when Emily was being like
so unbelievably are you banging right
okay
member when Emily was being so like
unrealistic and like unreasonable about
things that Ross had to do in order for
them to get back together and live
happily together as a married couple do
you know I'm talking about yes look this
is it it's like you can only change a
person so much mm-hmm and the end of the
day like they really are two totally
different people and the more I think
about like maybe they're not compatible
no they were never compatible and that
was the point it was like despite their
incompatibility it was their soulmate
love that you know could arise in
blossom through all of the things that
they're not meant like no I see there's
no opposite
but they were able to defy it but they
weren't you know it was too good to be
true like they didn't make any sense but
because they were like got married that
main sentence but no it's like no it
never means it'll be like you just
thought like wow he really made like an
honest woman out of her like her in her
Vivienne Westwood dress without wearing
she was like getting married in her
house in Nashville like that's totally
what Miley Stewart how she would have
got married yeah it was like a full
circle moment for us Hannah Montana fans
laughs Hollywood disappointing us once
again and Liam like I'm happy Miley has
found you know someone to spend her time
with I hope that I wish the best for
Liam I know Olivia culpo
is taken right now but I said that might
be yeah that that's it since that was a
great parent accident amazing pairing
yes she seems really happy though Olivia
couple right now so I feel like
Christians doing good things for her but
we haven't really gotten full
confirmation like maybe that was just
like a one-time thing and now she's
looking for Liam you don't take a trip
with him the one good thing yeah with
like another couple if you're like
barely a couple yeah you only do that
when you're married she's a great
athlete yeah I agree
oh you know we need to stop with
athletes everyone everyone keeps like
dating athletes and expecting a
different result and then like being
shocked when they do the same thing that
the last athlete did you know it's like
I know if I know that athletes are
untrustworthy like socio Khloe
Kardashian I agree I agree but everyone
thinks that they can change them well
here if there's someone out there I know
that there's someone listening to this
podcast that needs to hear this ready
you can't change a man so stop trying
okay thank you so home thank you um
while we're on breakup news I'm gonna
switch to our next story Morgan Stewart
and Brendan Fitzpatrick have officially
let us know that they've called it quits
right like this isn't surprising because
I've had a feeling about it but I'm just
shocked that they like admitted it
because every time Morgan posts on
Instagram like all the testers like
where's the right resurrect and like
some time the ring is there so it's like
maybe I really wasn't sure yeah no I I
was pretty sure but I understood why
they might need like time to announce it
maybe also they were separated seeing
how things went and if it was a
permanent think so you don't want an
announcer to
before it's done or else like everyone's
like clamoring for your man while you
still want him you know that's so true
I mean for her it's not a divorce it's a
separation they weren't married no like
no you get separated they're separate
they she mentioned it on nightly pop and
referred to it as a separation but I
just think she said that because the
first step in a divorce is a separation
yeah
but Hunter said divorce and she said not
divorce separation well gee she was just
clarifying they're not divorced yet
I don't think that I I don't think that
they're like I have no hope for them
getting back together and almost I think
like Morgan for the time that she was in
in her life when she got married like it
was the right thing to do but now she's
like really like a hustler a whole new
path she's on a whole new level like I
just think she can't be tied down right
now like and I actually think she's a
type of person where it's like her
career is moving so fast and like what
could catapult her it's dating Liam
Hemsworth you know what I mean I agree
actually I kind of ship like the blonde
couple Liam has Worth and I mean she's
like so [ __ ] gorgeous and like and
funny and smart like you don't get to be
always the perfect woman and you have
tits too like it's really unfair yeah
you never have like a great big body a
great face I'm a great personality and a
great job yeah you know it's not fair
yeah but you know she's struggling to
she's going through that stay true ever
you never know what's going on behind
closed doors so this was her statement
which was really sweet hi guys I know
many of you have been curious about the
current status of mine in Brendan's
relationship many of you got to know us
in our story through the show and feel
connected to us and for that we are
forever grateful I feel like she's
speaking directly to the toasters know
who are all so in 1000% Brendan and I
have spent six wonderful years together
but we have made the difficult decision
to go our separate ways I wanted to take
the time to clarify that our reason for
separating has nothing to do with
anything other than two people who sadly
grew apart deciding what's best for
themselves in the next phase of their
lives thank you from the bottom of my
heart for the extremely heartfelt and
supportive messages so many of you have
sent etcetera etc I mean this like it's
always sad when people break up but to
me this is there's something like that
was really healthy about this breakup
and I feel like neither one of them
wanted to be in the marriage anymore
like it wasn't one person leaving the
other devastated like I think Brendan
had moved on and I really think Morgan I
moved on like I think this is healthy
yeah there is something about breakups
but it's also something
really nice it's just like trimming the
fat like cutting out the root of the
problem and I'm having a fresh start for
people so like when people break up I'm
just like should have done it sooner
right and when you think about the
person that bread didn't married like
the Morgan from six years ago that we
saw on TV like she just wanted to be a
wife and we're Americans like that's so
not who she is anymore so people really
change and like I don't know what they
there's something sad obviously about a
divorce place didn't have any kids and I
just think it's like you know good on
you for like being self-aware enough to
know that it's time to move on yeah I
agree I'm gonna miss seeing her ring on
daily no and where is a cocktail you're
gonna miss her being just like a married
woman like but it's gonna be cool to
have like a single woman you know a
single host and this someone who likes
to watch like people's careers like
ascend into you know Fame who you dating
is so much a part of that and I think
like she she could really use like a
business memo you see something I feel
like she could use like a Jim toss you
know like those Witherspoon's husband
her agent yeah yeah no I'm thinking more
like a well-known Chaz's ex is available
I'm thinking more like a well-known
entrepreneur
oh you are yeah like not him but um that
snapchat guy Evan right oh my god that
would be so great yeah yeah that that
actually like a young Evan speak alike
who's like a tech entrepreneur on the
rise she's like also handsome I don't
know I don't know they yeah that's the
hard part a sec there's a lot of tech
entrepreneurs how many of them are
handsome
I also don't know a lot of entrepreneurs
I'm not really you know well versed in
up-and-coming entrepreneurs yeah agreed
but I agree a businessman go for her and
I think she's like she's a smart cookie
like I don't think she's going for an
athlete no she's [ __ ] smart she knows
you can't change a man and she's she's
in the Hollywood scene like she's seeing
people she's seen it I've seen it all
who date athletes and expect a different
outcome like she's and she's super smart
like whoever she dates next is the
luckiest man alive and I hope he
appreciates it
I agree maybe she's already dating
someone maybe it should be me I think I
think they've been separated for a long
time like yeah because there's been all
these dysregulation so it's possible
that they're each like seeing someone
yeah or like have been on dates and went
on Raya excuse me bless you okay well we
wish them the best
we do I'm excited to see what each of
them do next next up Jeffrey Epstein has
died source everyone's saying he
committed suicide I'm gonna put that in
air quotes because there's just no
[ __ ] way there's no [ __ ] way and I
hate that like if you think that Jeffrey
Epstein was murdered like you're a crazy
conspiracy here's the thing if you think
he committed suicide you're a crazy
conspiracy theorist you think he
committed suicide like you're naive if
you think that he was murdered like
you're you know you look at things with
a skeptical eye good for you if you
think that um his body was taken away
and he's gonna be living like another
life in another country you are a
conspiracy theory and I see you I know
you yeah I never thought of that because
he was rolled out yeah without a lie not
a bodybugg because they were trying to
resuscitate him or you know maybe his um
he'll be cremated and then you know
spend his life living in jungles of
Cambodia I never thought in his [ __ ]
Island do you see the reddit thread like
one of the nurses was like Zola I don't
know there was like a hole ready I don't
want to get it wrong but there was like
they were told us to do like bla bla bla
these things it's like not the
conventional thing to do like something
was up okay he's totally alive I didn't
even think of that as a possibility
I was literally fighting with people
this week and they were like talk about
Jeffrey Epstein I'm like you don't even
know like I've been known about the
island for years like you're in years
behind and I didn't even think to even
discuss like the possibility that this
could have been a stage and like he's
gonna live in Canada like James Taylor
did for dancing whatever but he has his
own Islands like why would he I guess
they could find anyways so I guess I
could read like the actual facts or we
could continue to speculate which feels
right to me you know the facts are that
I'm leged Lee he committed suicide in
his jail cell the chapter starts dating
him and now he's dead
yeah all the facts like don't mine up so
he was on suicide watch for a while
because apparently he had tried to
commit suicide a few weeks before but in
recent days they said that he was
actually like in really good spirits he
was no longer on suicide watch and he
had said that someone was trying to hurt
him so obviously a lot of people have a
lot to win from him like no longer being
on trial right because the more he's on
trial the more paperwork comes out the
more names gets filled and like as much
as everyone thinks like oh good
affiliates like nobody's a pedophile
like Hollywood is filled with pedophiles
and Jeffrey Epstein was the one
connector between all the powerful
people in Hollywood who'd like to amaze
little boys
like every area right everybody's not
Werfel people um but what was also
interesting was that he a didn't have a
cell mate because his cell mate was
transferred and B he wasn't being
supervised in at the time that it
happened which are two like protocols of
the jail that that those are again
that's against protocol like if you if
you have previously tried to commit
suicide you're you must have a jail a
cellmate and you must be supervised at
all times so it's like just an oversight
like do to understaffing that's what
they said that they had to break these
two protocols like for the most
important men in their jail cell like
but when you think about Jeffrey Epstein
and his friends and clientele and the
people who benefited from their
relationship with him like and how
powerful every single one of those
people are it's like how do how would he
not have escaped like how would he not
have been murdered like how was this
ever gonna go to trial we don't stand a
chance you guys no never eat instant
umpires for us to go you know the right
way and he's not to be bribed and for
him apparent that you can now keep on
even crazier in the Commons they're like
the person on the stretcher wasn't him
no actually it looks a lot like him he
said he has different different ears I
think it was interesting I didn't look
at the years ya know like there's the
his first suicide attempt I'm like oh
it's over like I really thought like he
was either gonna escape so the fact that
we made it this long and got this much
paperwork and like now people to know
about the island they have the the
blueprints of the island and like the
the paperwork they had to file with like
the local city zoning committee like we
we got a lot we got more than we were
ever gonna get
I hope the road doesn't like stop here I
hope someone continues to have a say but
so crazy is like you think like the
justice system can get him but it's like
his ring of paedophilia like bleeds into
the justice system like there are judges
and DA's like who are part of this so
it's like there's so many people like we
were never gonna get a conviction like
it was a nice try America but no it
really was um so now I would just like
answers as to what happened cuz he he
either was like saved by a friend or
killed by an and me great cuz you think
about it like there are so many people
that say what didn't happen
he didn't commit there are so many
people who would be implicated like so
many powerful rich connected people who
either wanted him dead or wanted him out
of prison like I don't know
there were more people who wanted him to
be dead or more people who needed him to
get off scot-free so the possibility of
him being murdered or being escaped are
just as equally possible no totally and
I think it would just go back to like
what kind of guy he was to his friends
like jay-z's friends would they be
happier seeing him alive or seeing him
dead
right this is a good friend was he a
mean pedophilia ring operator or a
behind pedophilia ring operator and
there's no way to know unless you were
part of the pedophilia ring so we'll
have to talk to you I don't know someone
else but you just see that someone the
investigation like isn't over and
prosecutors will continue to focus on
those who have may have helped him in
executing this sex trafficking ring but
you guys the kingpin it's gone like did
you see that someone took over chalk and
wrote outside his townhouse right after
he was committed suicide signed bill and
Hilary a lot of people think that Bill
and Hillary are behind this and there's
this thing called the Clinton body count
like there's over 60 people who they
attribute their death to Bill and
Hillary Clinton so that's also like an
hour running conspiracy theory that'll
have to look into okay I think that's
like deeper in the conspiracy like but
it could be anyone like there so momma
got totally rich famous powerful people
like and also I don't know that it was a
what I don't think they were a one-man
you know I think that all the people who
could possibly be implicated in this
pool their resources that all got
together there was a meeting of the
months in a conference room somewhere me
but then you know what it goes back to
what empty I was reading like the Google
Camp thing wherever all the rich and
powerful people were together last week
Jeffrey Epstein turns up dead and David
Geffen had like all the movers and
shakers on his yacht like for a secret
meeting now this is really conspiracy
theory no but the possibility no I'll
just meet all the rich and powerful
people think it'd be smarter than to
realize like directly after their
meeting like something crazy happens
they should have waited like I don't
even care they're not clearly not afraid
of the justices right of so true we have
a good answer to why would they be
afraid oh my god well that just really
shook me right there there's something
when could they all have met last week
at the meeting we talked about it and
they all took their planes and you know
what they're actually smart to have all
taking their planes in
they're boats and have the conversation
be about how hypocritical they are right
cuz everyone must focus on but really
going yes so true oh my gosh
scene thing makes you mother [ __ ] tank
I thinking I'm really thinking I know I
mean even you guys just blew my mind
with him totally not being dead like
there's literally no way yeah yeah
there's no way he's alive no way he's
alive
no no way yeah he's alive yeah there's
no way he's dead so I was reading
somewhere that they said like if
something happens to the body where it's
like oh we accidentally cremated him you
know we got the wrong instructions then
if we get news like that he's alive also
an interesting tailspin embarassingly
literally so mortifying Jeffrey Epstein
is Jewish and Jewish people do not get
cremated so if he does get cremated that
will be very interesting Jewish people
don't do a lot of things that he's been
doing very true I don't think yeah I
don't think he's you know the long yeah
it says in the Torah like don't have an
island where you bring underage girls to
and share them with all the power most
powerful in the world
that's very true it just says yeah he
broke that commandment I think I read
that once yeah yeah gachi it was like a
brace I got two matching identical
pimples on my chin this weekend do you
see them
I keep like picking them yes it was just
like it was kind of exciting you know
like so symmetrical you know when do you
get like two pimples at the same time
like when you get a pimple I can become
obsessed with it you like fixate on
about I got two well you know what I
feel as though we need that pimples you
should get more than one like it should
be a cluster if it really is like a
backing up right if and if it's like
filled with bacteria like why would it
only manifest in one pimple I don't know
I guess you just had so much bacteria
now are you staring at the two-bit moles
no because your big lip is covering it
my big lip big lip you know after I got
lip injections last time I was like I
don't think I'm gonna do it again let me
feel like really silly like now I just
look at pictures I'm like I think my
lips are getting smaller I think it's
time to go back
I think the tough thing about lip
injections it's like it's a three-month
period it's a sale until you love
there's forty days where you love them
and you don't know how to live without
them after that like I don't think you
can go back to your thinlits like no now
I look at my time hoppin a you suck my
time up and be like wow my fat face now
I look at my time I'm like holy [ __ ] my
little lips yeah like you know I support
you guys I
I'm up I think this inches lips look
great right now
yeah me too they've been looking really
good this week yeah but Margot like I
think you looked back for a while oh I
did the first week I looked insane I did
the first three weeks like okay the
first three months nobody you look right
right now but how do we stay like this
forever but maybe her let's just went
back to normal and that's know my top of
his way bigger we should have taken
better before-and-after pictures yeah
but I do take selfies every day you
should be mobile I really liked it today
whatever recipes Jeffrey Epstein
wherever you are yeah actually sorry
don't rest rest and not in peace in war
yeah what's opposite of recipes for no
sorry burn in hell yeah roll over in
your grave yeah anyways craziness crazy
I just I don't know how we go from
Jeffrey Epstein's like you know escape
from prison to I'm Ashley and Jared's
wedding but but here we are but here we
go
because bachelor in paradise alums
Ashley I and now Ashley H and Jared hi
bond are now married Jared hi bond is a
bachelor no more on Sunday he married
fellow bachelor in paradise allah masha
eddie in rhode island where the groom
grew up quote jared and i from the very
beginning have been saying we don't want
our wedding to be a party we want it to
be a romantic experience oh that's so
funny I always wanted the opposite like
I only wanted my wedding to be a [ __ ]
rager no totally joy 980 of their
closest family and friends including
Nick vile who was looking like a snackie
oh he bug lightened his beard
yeah he was something was working for
him I hope he like you know caught some
tail at the wedding people think he's
dating Rachel Bilson I think he's dating
retreat you and so hopefully he didn't
hook up with anyone else if you're
dating Rachel they'll say honestly he
must have the biggest penis like he
keeps hitting celebrities he'll like
January Jones yeah no I don't think it's
small it's no it's I think it's like a
horse monumental like enormous it has to
be yeah but like January Jones told
everyone personality so I don't know
that it has to be horse sized no but
like there are a lot of handsome fellas
from The Bachelor likewise dick vile
different than all the others cuz he's a
horse penis yeah just I'm gonna think
about yeah Ben Higgins was there Dean
was there looking good and I've really
turned a corner on me too and now I just
like really like to see what he's up to
actually it started that way member when
he was on retail in DC's and yeah and I
literally was writing fanfiction about
him and Raven gates is what they might
be doing in paradise that didn't work
out it turned out even better for her
and Adam yeah um and then he obviously
you know [ __ ] up but I'm back to like
Dean Stan level me too and when the
commercials for him empowered I see is
his crazy hair and also a mustache and
I'm not feeling it but now he's the
crazy hair no mustache Adam into it I
love it I actually really like the long
hair Michio it's handsome yeah everyone
at this wedding there were so many
people there like I guess I behind your
maybe of their closest friends and fam
and they were all from The Bachelor
that's what I'm saying like Jared and
Ashley I guess if you think about it
have been in the franchise for so long
and so content continued to be relevant
in the franchise so there are people who
were invited who are like new franchisee
people but then also they'd like super
old swell I mean Elon kale was the
officiator and he no longer as a
producer on The Bachelor but he was
there forever
yeah um Kaitlyn Bristowe and Jason were
there
Becca Tilly Olivia Carini like super
random Amanda Stan yeah I I guess have
been at least one hook up within like
the bachelor world of single people yeah
honestly I know Ben Ben Higgins bring
his girlfriend yes I saw her in a story
okay cute because I was gonna like what
were you gonna conject like him and
Olivia crazy like never got a fair shot
oh my god that's so true a Charlie
forgot that she was on the season yeah I
like legitimately forgot about her well
after New York ya know and she like will
ease off the grid except she releases a
podcast once a week yeah I didn't see I
want to see I hadn't stopped the wedding
fully because we were having him a nice
time yesterday but it looked really nice
she looked so beautiful
she looked great and both of her dresses
I really like like so classic her she
wanted like romance fairytale and she
did like a poufy princess wedding dress
but I loved it yeah no I loved it and
then her second dress was great too it
was like more contemporary with like a
halter but she just has a bangin body
and she's beautiful and she's great too
so she could really wear anything but
check to fiying women lately like men no
but like i live i'll i deemed tation i'm
like your tits are great like i need to
relax like i've been objectified i am
like the female gays like remember when
we learned that in college like I've got
a say yeah
Morgan Stewart she'll be slapping you
with yeah also like I just like with hey
without a guy this weekend so I was like
kids ass [ __ ] you know like I got a show
yeah I said something disgusting you're
not talking about like models that we
think are beautiful I'm like like who we
would go gay for and I was like hey top
Jen and I literally I said something so
disgusting like I can't believe that
came out of my mouth I was just like I
said I'm like if Kate Upton would let me
like no no I would eat her out that's
what I said that I'd like said I'm like
I gotta relax I've been hanging out with
too many men and one in your man say he
wasn't there okay because maybe he's
second liam hemsworth : anything why no
I wouldn't say I mean I respect
that's good say behind it I'm like in
love with these pimples on my chin like
I just want to scratch him off my face I
can't stop touching them um anything
else from the wedding that okay never
mind was I mean it we can only talk
about your pimples for so long sorry
from the wedding that was noteworthy
counts vomiting snatchler expert yeah I
know he's at Gurney's know what the
wedding was at the least a daiquiri yeah
oh right a party where Becca was there
this weekend she like was saying she saw
them all weekend nobody told her to put
in the toasters job did she see anything
good interesting I'll have to have
follow up with her
the wedding was out of church and then
the ceremony was at I mean the reception
was mansion it was pretty something
ballroom rose a mint not really
mentioned yeah Rose rose maybe Rose
mansion bro Sun ballrooms like in Queens
Jackie but something room yes room okay
well and it was really well done yeah
it's always nice when a bachelor couple
gets a happy ending because it gives the
franchise like maybe one more year of
like legitimacy yeah it's also just
weird because so many of the weddings
are televised and I have to assume this
will be televised somewhere but when
they're televised like I never see a
picture a snapchat of nothing like Carly
and Evan or crystal and goose glitter
they just got married like I didn't see
a quarter of a picture like oh but this
one was so heavily
honestly I think it's because the
toasters witness it but crystal and
goose it was in Mexico on bachelor in
paradise so like I know deserving get
toasters down there right that's true I
guess everything does come back to the
toasters you know it's really truly
there were boots on the ground like
everyone is in Newport like seeing video
2g but
paradise is like you know you can't get
in there unless you work there well now
that the wedding is over I hope they're
having wedded bliss and real
I really hope they used to let to keep
everything organized for them because
they could either be in wedded bliss
right now or tarcher bel and it's just
based on his decision on whether or not
they use illa yeah I have to believe
that they they were smart enough to use
Ola Zola is the wedding company that
will do anything for love they're
reinventing the wedding planning and
registry experience to make the happiest
moments in couple's lives even happier
from engagement to wedding and
decorating your first home Zola is there
combining compassionate customer service
with modern tools and technology all in
the service of love so it was the
easiest way to plan your wedding and
register they take the stress out of
wedding planning with free wedding
websites the easiest wedding registry
affordable invite Suites and more
they're conveniently managed over
everything online and in one place with
over 90,000 five-star reviews from
couples and guests explore Zola's
beautiful wedding invites have a fall
wedding it's time to order oh my god if
you are having a fall wedding it is time
to order your invitations and do like
menus right I didn't know that Zola did
that so you can order your invites and
day of paper through Zola they've added
thousands of invitation designs for
every style and color scheme their
prices are friendly wedding paper
shouldn't blow your budget I totally
agree because it's literally going in
the trash easily build your whole suite
that's all out they've got save the
dates invites day of papers programs and
menus and thank-you cards too Wow okay
so head to Sola vol a.com slash toast
and get 30% off your invites and paper
orders so we know we have a lot of
toasty brides if you didn't know you can
get all your paper needs
that's menus programs imitations
thank-you cards save the dates you can
get them all through Zola and if you use
the the link as Ola comm slash toast you
can get 30% off your invites and your
paper order that's zo L a.com slash
toast for 30% off your invitations and
paper orders okay exciting Zola
they've been final story before we bring
out Tamra judge drunk Taylor has sweep
the internet she threw a party
celebrating the nominations for you need
to come down and me and she invited all
the people who were part of it so
obviously a lot of celebrities were a
part of you need to calm down a lot of
them came the burton-cox was there and
they were all just like story and you
can see Taylor in the background and
then she kind of becomes like the
fixation she was like wasted and was
sitting to her own song and like doing
interpretive dances and I've just
personally never related sure like on
more of a level like singing your own
song I do that now and also like
interpretive dancing to songs I
that as well um probably the best part
to come out of this is that in someone's
Instagram stories they're not filming
Taylor but you can hear in the
background and she's talking about how
she's in love with cardi B oh that's so
cute yeah like obviously like other
people get in trouble like you're
filming and you hear them in the
background like talking [ __ ] about
someone but I was just talking about all
of her cardi B yeah uh it's actually a
funny thing that's happened right she's
becoming me he's never really seen her
drunk nor did we ever think that we
might because like that's no antithesis
of her personality no but recently like
after reputation she like talks about
getting drunk we've never seen it she's
always like talking about wine yeah but
no like now it's like proof is in the
pudding oh did I tell you guys that I
became a Liz I stand I think I did yeah
I don't know I thought we should bring
it up um she honestly was like a hot
mess hot [ __ ] mess like image label
is happiness sparkly dress with like her
crazy hair in front of her face and then
she became a meme like people were
cutting out junk Taylor's body and like
putting it at McDonald's and that's
funny that's funny this is kind of like
the the viral moment she like so
desperately needed she really did
because every other viral moment of hers
is never gonna have planned and I can't
imagine like this was or else not
planned
it's very negative ya know she but she's
it's like that's a drunk person or an
actress it looks so fun like why wasn't
I invited it's not fair maybe one day
like do you ever have FOMO from places
like you would never ever be at like
FOMO she really only be reserved for
moments like you should have been out
like right yesterday right like you guys
spending the weekend together like
normally I would have been there I'm so
me having FOMO seems totally reasonable
of me having fun for an event I'm like I
literally in know possibility could I
ever have been invited to like that
seems unreasonable to me I guess but
maybe you feel as though like you should
have been invited is that like because
like my entitlement part and above it
was chose my entitlement that's to me
it's like you invite you because you
beat him you know what that makes sense
that makes me feel a little bit better
uh so nobody tell us the type of woman
like she can't stomp on other people's
success yesterday she was at the Teen
Choice Award which was the weirdest
award ceremonies ever like held outside
with five people in the audience and I
just didn't know anything that was
coming on hosted by Lucy hill and david
dobrik who were like outside with the
wind blowing in their face it was so
weird that is that is quite strange so
I'm assuming she was hungover Taylor yes
but you know they didn't start till like
4:00 or 5:00 o'clock so she definitely a
PD like no but like she definitely
didn't start her making she started
make about like 1200 dress yeah that's
so rough she was totally hungover but
also I feel like she's the type of girl
who throws a party and like it's over at
11:00 you know yeah but like this level
of drugs like she had to have thorough
not yeah throwing that makes you feel
better no but then you're depleted but
she definitely like gets IVs and stuff
like yeah she's right you know like
famous people like have a way of getting
around these normal people problems but
if you like something like you think for
an award show like people spend days
preparing like chase masters
yeah like doing like a blood transfusion
and it's cool to see that like no she's
hungover for a big event and by the way
she's never looked better
she should do it more often she looks
good she looks amazing last night yeah
love that outfit like so mature
she also announced that she's gonna be
releasing a single on Friday called
lover which is the title track of her
album people think it's like a whole
conspiracy that she actually got married
it's a conspiracy that Jeffrey Epstein
is alive and living in Canada similar
but she's like in the Bogue article that
she released they released one of the
lyrics from lover and it's um my heart
is blue yours is borrowed so something
blue something borrowed there's
something there might be something there
yeah whatever any last night they like
don't walk red carpets together no we're
at the party I didn't see no mix yeah
but like he's like always in London I
don't know that's not gonna we forget
that she's gonna let you just you a
teacher and then it's Miley and Liam
like oh they really weren't together
they're not supporting each other yeah
but no the music can always tell us like
what's what's going on in the music
scene is really positive king of my
heart body and soul like they're very
much yeah and she's an American girl
yeah American Queen me I'm your American
Queen and you move to a hotel right home
last night and it was amazing I was
trying to listen to country music for
two and a half hours it's like you know
like a it's only band but then we listen
to king of my heart and I was just like
why did she say American like that
I don't know but I is there a theory no
but I firmly believe they're king of my
heart is one of the best songs on
reputation it's not hard okay we are
gonna take a quick break and we're gonna
bring out Tamra judge Real Housewife of
Orange County our inaugural Real
Housewife of Orange County so head over
to our Instagram drop a question for
Tamra judge people do our absolute best
to get them straight to where go get a
snack meet Sally of the watercooler
come back as we'll be back in about five
minutes so stay tuned
you
you
welcome back to the morning to us we are
very excited to have business owners
housewives I don't even know what to
introduce you guys because you guys are
just truly now a relationship goal
relationship Tamra and Eddie judge we
are so excited to have you we have been
a Tamra judge Stan since season one me
specifically like I have wrote it out
and I'm so glad that we made it here you
know what I mean yeah you aren't it's
it's like you were just so great and I
love you and you guys are here because
you has a brand new CBD company we do
well which is so great now eight months
old yeah I am CBD kind of sore so
excited we brought you both some
products yeah so you you guys tell me
how you use CBD because you we saw on
the show last season went through a
little a little something with your
heart which was pretty serious
um and CBD has so many medical benefits
and you guys probably know more than me
but tell me about your journey to CBD
and how you now started this new company
yeah so we actually look we started
looking into CB CBD like two years ago
when it first started to you know come
to surface maybe three years now Wow and
you know we we we started looking into
it talking to people and also the THC
side as well and then we got worried
yeah we got a little bit worried if the
laws were a little bit different back
then we were a afraid like being a
public figure that we'd have like the
DEA knocking on the front door property
and we're like look I know we got a
little scared right but since then the
the farm bill passed and it became legal
so we're like okay you know right before
that we knew it was coming up right so
our dog had gotten cancer and it just
kind of reassured that this is the path
that we need to go on because everyone
was saying give them CBD give them CBD
and so we really said you know what
we're doing this is meant to be like
yeah we were just doing this and we just
started the CBD company called Dena
wellness Venus CBD it's Vina I don't
know if you know it Vina is no we all
have a vena cava in us and it's
basically the two main arteries that
bring blood up to your heart important
yeah
so we thought that it was brilliant
considering Eddie had gone through or
still going through a lot of heart
issues and we had no idea what we were
about to do because we just it just
flooded I mean people are just obsessed
with CVT I'm obsessed with CVT I take it
every night before bed oh good so it
helps you stay asleep I just like wake
up and be super Restless yep now I'm
like a brick do you would take tincture
so do you take pills I take like gummy
bears
so we are zombie not with gummy all
right I think it's such a great product
like I literally just find myself eating
them because it's like fun and delicious
well that's Eddie because he loves gummy
bears because he was really pushing for
the the gummies so what kind of products
do you guys have now you have creams we
have a cream we haven't ensuring we have
gel caps oh yeah you think it's good
when you put that thing in your mouth
it's gonna chase but it doesn't someone
give us immediately a chocolaty like
bummed out when you found the other one
yeah and then I went to sleep and I fell
asleep so deeply yeah everybody
metabolize the CBD differently so what
works for you might not work for me yeah
so for instance like my son who does do
THC my oldest son he's thirteen not that
younger like she probably does too I
don't know he's 19 so he you know he's
like mom come on like it's not gonna do
anything for me and so he took it and
he's like I don't have headaches anymore
so you know everybody has to metabolize
yeah everybody has there's metabolizes
it differently have you shared your
stuff with the cast of our enchantee how
they mellowed out at all yeah all right
yeah one in particular mr. Kelly Dodd
could benefit from the you know the
benefits of CBD
I'm not gonna disagree with that yeah
yeah
we saw are we gonna see more of your
journey this season I'm actually I'm I'm
on the mend that's great it's almost 95%
better exercising my heart which was my
condition was interpolation it's done
it's fixed my doctors it's America work
and fix me now among men yeah dr. Natale
out of Texas is amazing it works on like
presidents and royalty and we were so
lucky to look and yeah he took on Eddie
and we he had gone through quite a few
doctors prior to that different types of
lesions because there is so many
different types of ablations that you
can have done and he he really it took
him a while and he said he was a very
tough case like yet he was in surgery
and he came out afterward to scratching
his head he's like I've never seen
anything like somebody so young and so
fit so crazy it's like you a picture of
health
yeah you want a gym yeah company so you
know looking back at the things that I
used to do which I'm probably gonna do
again push myself to exercise too hard
too long and not replenish not um not
replenished my my vitamins and minerals
my yeah that's really the only thing I
can think of but pushing myself hard is
not something that is um not uncommon
you know there's a lot of athletes out
there that push themselves or didn't
they don't have this issue they do they
do and you know the doctor can tell me
what it caused what causes the issue but
it was it was part of my I guess
genetics right and I just accelerated it
because of my lifestyle and the biggest
takeaway is you don't have to kill
yourself to exercise and stay healthy
before we got here I had five miles to
go run but I only had 45 minutes to get
ready where did you run five miles in
Central Park
beautiful yeah tendency to miss
calculate routes and everybody
I say we're gonna go do you know 3/4
mile run and I'll take my team out for
about 10 miles were you trying to join a
country club I mean actually up tonight
from our Country Club choice dancing
show Barisan but we're still we're not
giving up and when you were running
around your kitchen with your entire
life I'm 51 years old to be a member of
a Country Club
so I was just running around like joking
I mean it was a restaurant and you can
just go in there and you don't have to
link it conservation that's it yeah and
you have to be and you have to be a club
member beautiful watching you guys on
the past few seasons has truly been like
watching a like home renovation show of
the Orange County because I feel like
I've seen all the right neighborhoods
and I'm really happy with where you
landed like I love that in your last
house and loved your kitchen like that
little booth oh yeah I do love that that
was ooh love that
but your homey added that one is
stunning so I just had an article today
that said that I left my old house
because I couldn't afford it anymore and
that I didn't have any more money so I
had to buy a more expensive house right
right nothing else better to do
no it's a beautiful house do you feel at
home there now yeah we do yeah instantly
that last house we had we just didn't
feel at home and it was like one of
those just feelings like you went home
and your help your home is your safe
place comfortable dinner feel
comfortable there even
love the backyard but we were crammed in
the cul-de-sac and we felt I felt
claustrophobic right and so the real
estate agent my friend called me and
said have somebody's looking for a house
just like yours you want to sell it he
was in the hospital at the time and I'm
like sure go ahead and she Spencer's
home go ahead
showed it somebody else actually bought
it like the next day and it was a 14-day
escrow all-cash deal it was like meant
to be meant to be yeah and then my other
girlfriend that lives in Coto goes hey I
just heard you sold your house and I go
yeah she goes I had just have a listing
that's such your style went in we're
like love it bought it it was got it it
was just one of those things we just
hope in about a week yeah and our
neighbors with Vickie how was that
around town yeah we're far enough when
you guys find out that that was gonna be
the case we actually got a phone call
from producers after we all signed
contracts Vicki didn't say anything to
us I think she kind of felt bad but he
explained to us what the deal was and
was a little shocked you knew while you
were filming oh yeah we all knew she
knew she knew - got it going into it so
we found out we're like whoa like we
it's just kind of shocking to all of us
it is the OGS yeah so but the thing is
the crazy thing is that she's in it a
lot and most of the drama that happens
on the show this year is surrounded by
her that's always what happens like with
the friend of housewife like Camille on
Beverly Hills like some other always at
the center of the drama but they're not
an official cast mate yeah it's so it's
I'd work harder I want to take some
questions from people on Instagram this
is from Rach Everhart if you could bring
back any old housewife who would it be
Heather Heather a week after that was
like well you know what there's a
certain cast member on our show that she
would never work with so oh right and
that leads me to my next question
yeah Britt Montanaro um can we get a
status update with you in Kelly dog cuz
fans of the show we're watching
something that happened what like six or
eight months ago yeah I mean now new
things are happening we follow you guys
on social media and it's like we're
confused yeah well you're I am confused
as well just so you know and for the
record you will continue to see me
support Kellie Dodd throughout the
season I was her biggest supporter every
time that she got into a fight I would
pull her away and like try to talk her
down did nothing to her nothing and she
like a wild animal turned on me like
just turn and I'm like I mean I'm
literally in scenes going what did I do
she tried to turn the entire cast
against me but it didn't work but I
don't understand why she did it yeah so
I will find out when I watch it
I've asked the cast members I'm like why
did she do this and they're like we have
no idea
we have no idea whatsoever and now she's
going out on social media and just
blasting me blasting my house my husband
your house oh yeah I know she even says
it in tomorrow's episode but last week
it was a two million dollar teardown and
her neighborhood so I don't know what
she's doing I think she's projecting I
think that she knows that what's to come
and I didn't do anything to her which
says she's trying to get the public to
think that I'm this horrible person that
said horrible think I didn't know I did
not I mean we've watched you on the show
you've been on my TV for a while and
you've always been a really good friend
and yeah most recently like you have
really like stood up for Shannon and
you've been such a good friend to
Shannon and now just to see her being in
such a good place yes how does that feel
like you feel like a bigger part of that
yes yes reason for it I am I'm so happy
for Shannon like we went through some
bumpy yeah times last year for us yet so
she's gone through a lot you know and I
had been in her spot before being you
know going through a divorce and not
quite as bad as hers because I think she
didn't want it yeah but to see her now
is like you know she looks so good look
so good she's happy she has a new man
yes we met him he was nice guy nice guy
very nice very good-looking here very
like shannon's of smoke show she is
she'll stick to them together I'm like
what Oh a new power couple literally
everyone is dating now that's what's so
funny is like the evolution of the show
is like now Kelly as a new man is
already still together the doctor and
Kelly I mean she breaks up on social
media all the time I'm using that
whatever e45 does this question is from
Megan Lynn
Wyatt 51 do you look better than me at
2500 series I've been making amazing
Megan was are there a point in your life
where you decided to put health and
fitness first or have you always been
yeah I mean I have to say that I've
always been into fitness my job out of
high school was working at LA Fitness so
I'm sure I was always really into
fitness and then there was a time when I
was having kids where you know it wasn't
a big priority anymore because I had
little kids right and so after Sophia I
think probably a few probably by the
time she was five I'm like okay I want
to get back into shape like I was before
and I had I'd been on the show and then
when I met Eddie we just took it into a
whole nother yeah I just want and now
you're the face of your business so
that's motivation to say yeah I just I
just keep going like I didn't have to go
run five miles today wait I didn't want
to run and it forced her I woke up I was
ready to go I just you know it's a
lifestyle and I see the benefit it is
now and aren't at my age and five years
older than him but at my age it's more
about wanting that to be healthy it's
not so much about what it does for me
but just to be healthy like I was
getting to a point where I couldn't move
and joints are starting slow and things
like that so I'm like I yeah um this is
a hilarious question how do you feel
about kind of being in the meme Hall of
Fame for that's my opinion like you oh
no we're cemented into internet culture
with that's my opinion well let me just
tell you because I'm not really from
that generation that even I didn't even
know what it mean was when right oh my
my daughter Sophia she's like mom this
is ridiculous
she goes I'll be around the lunch table
and I'll hear people go so she went up
to somebody wants to ghost
you know that's my mom right because
they don't watch the Housewives no it's
not yes yes it is so now at school like
people will go up to her and go that's
my that's honestly epic and then
multiple kids teenagers have sent me
messages including my oldest daughter
who put that as their senior senior
quote that's a great senior quote so
Sydney has in her so she graduated three
years ago that's my opinion
mom yeah so it's like it's crazy right
it's hilarious like in that moment like
well I was thinking about that's - let's
talk about doing a podcast and saying oh
my god yeah and also you guys have a
code for being a wellness for the
toasters right it's code toast if anyone
wants to buy the sisters DVD there's an
entire subgroup devoted to it so what's
the website
it is Vina CBD calm and that's the ene
ene use code 20% up thank you guys so
much for coming thank you for listening
follow Tamara on Instagram half Tamra
judge obviously and that is your
Instagram any judge any judge yeah off
the judges yeah people think that the
Mets player our judges your judge we
call them Tamra judges CBD calm used
Koto's for 20% off and we'll be back
tomorrow so we'll see you tomorrow
morning 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time have a
good day bye thanks guys
you